what do your kids think of you as
aquaman though really when they saw the
movie is that kind of cool for them
because they're so young and really
getting into that it was perfect i mean
they they grew up with justice league so
they got to you know wear the tiara from
i mean
he was obsessed with batman wolf he was
so yeah he gets to wear everything and
be in the batmobile and but um yeah and
the first time i saw it i actually
waited because i wanted to see with my
babies and so we went to the premiere
and saw it together and that's exciting
wolfie's extremely emotional until like
when i'd get hurt or beat up he'd be
like crying and i'm like buddy papa's
right here i mean
it's all right
but we don't have we don't have tv we
don't have tv and we don't know that on
phones or any of that stuff so like they
don't get good
yeah just because their little
imaginations are growing and it's like
let them have that they're the rest of
their life to watch all the time i agree
you're a good dad okay my kids
my kids love you as aquaman is it cool
if i bring them out and maybe they ask
you a couple questions to meet you come
on out grammy come on river
do you want to give aquaman a hug you
want to get drunk
are you nervous
come here are you nervous
i do
i do have kids okay you want to sit here
i'll sit her by him and then you can sit
okay here i'll set you right here you're
good you're good goodness hi
yeah
i talk like i don't know if they're
gonna usually my son is so funny because
usually remy's on the bed when we're
watching and or like he's like he's like
i'm aquaman
he's like you got aquaman shoes on right
now oh my god he's gonna be quiet okay
rib why don't you take over you have a
question for him yeah i forgot okay go
ahead oh you forgot here i'll tell you
you told me in the thing
do you know a little mermaid
that was her question in my office and i
was like ask him
ariel yeah she's she ariel's very sweet
she's very nice she's also a redhead so
yeah i'm gonna teach you about redhead
someday
they're they're very passionate very
passionate people
that is true here you had you had
another question in the office you want
me to okay here i'll help you okay
because they were like this is the best
part they wrote out cards for her and
i'm like she's in kindergarten
she was learning how to read oh thank
you did you make that verb oh my god our
friend oh my god that's so nice
that's very sweet awesome
aquaman
okay
man guy to a bathroom that's what she
asked in office where does aquaman go to
the bathroom
[Laughter]
everywhere
that's it because you're in the water
all the time oh my god do you want to
ask me anything you want to say anything
remy hey
you like aquaman you want ya
come
she's like she's the she's the talker
and he's the sensitive one he's like
you just chill with aquaman he's chill
you're chilling
he's so excited all right well you guys
did awesome good job good job
we are excited about the batman so
we are excited
so what can you tell us about it you
play penguin i play yeah i play oz um uh
who's kind of hasn't embodied the
penguin yet but is known as the penguin
basically because he has a bit of a
uh
awkward gate
um
and yeah it was it was it was a oh yeah
there it is uh a really extraordinary
makeup artist called mike mourinho kind
of designed the character i will say
what wait that's not you though yeah
wait what yeah
wait what
i didn't see that picture oh my god i
just heard that you were a penguin what
the hell you haven't seen that person
deserves to win a warrior oh no no he
should yeah yeah
that's you no it's amazing it's it's
amazing what he was k and he designed he
did i couldn't download the photo last
night and i kept telling her i was like
i never saw him as penguin it's amazing
oh my god the first time i saw the
makeup was they had done a he had done a
mold of uh my
face and and
i saw it on a screen on matt reeves
screen the director the writer director
of the batman he said you want to see
what what mike marino's done what he
thinks what he thinks ours are going to
look like and i said yeah and he showed
me the screen i just i didn't know it
was going in that direction and i went
holy smoke and i'd never done anything
like that before and i can't kind of
take too long four hours
at the start four hours and then they
got it down to two and it was fine
because i knew what the reward was
immense and it was you're a different
human it was extraordinary
did you ever go out liberating
no we did uh i would have gone out and
we did a test
until you find out they're like sorry
never heard of them oh checked ego
so let's talk about your show so it's
called naomi i'm very into superhero
thing all things superhero i'm very end
so you are a superhero now show right
yes that's what it is okay so what who
is naomi naomi is a 16 year old girl who
loves superman which is really funny
because it's a superhero show and she
loves superman she's a big comic book
fan she's the third biggest superman fan
site in the world look how cute you are
thank you thank you she's the third
biggest superman fan site in the world
and then an event happens in our town
and superman comes and from there she
figures out her hidden destiny and
figures out how powerful she really
really is
i'm in i love these things i love
watching them with my kids too so wait
so here's the comic book um the show is
based on
so you can see her character arc in the
covers from fan to finding out who she
is and and to being a part of the
superheroes club so was this like a cool
that were you are you a superhero fan of
things like this or was this a cool role
to get to play when i got the audition i
was like whoever books this this is
going to be like really good for them i
would love to see this and then it
turned out to be me but i love this
season thank you
thank you that's so exciting
it's like
whoever books this this is going to be
so cool and like a fun dream role it is
a dream role and with miss ava on the
team and it's rare that you're playing
like your age i always feel like people
always like so i'm playing this person
said never not their age it's like oh
you're actually the age that's amazing
so your character has become a role
model for girls so is that
i know it has to feel good but do you
feel any pressure ever because you're
like representing it i you know you feel
pressure with everything i think me
being authentically i started the show
when i was 16 i'm 17 being that age and
then authentically being a black girl
and knowing that experience it really
helps but i feel an honor to be a part
of the representation and to even get
dms or messages about my hair in the
show and how the braids represent so
many people in real life and they don't
see that reflected all the time in the
media is great
well you're in one of the big movies
this summer the suicide squad are you so
stoked oh my god i'm really excited yeah
i'm excited i love the posters how look
they are i think how good they look i'm
so excited i'm into like anything like
this it's like any super any like group
i'm into anything like this were you as
a kid i was i was since i was a little
kid i loved comic books yeah and i was
actually
really really blessed that he was able
to do a marvel film which is new mutants
a while ago and now yeah suicide squad
which is dc which for a nerd kid that i
was it's those different yeah
and this one i think the fans are really
going to love it because james gunn the
director he's so brilliant he directed
um
guardians of the galaxy yeah which i
love i love it and it's so much fun
there's so much laugh in it even though
there's explosions and all the craziness
the comedy in those films are always my
fav it's because the moments were that's
the best kind of comedy just by the
trailer you're gonna see the vibe of the
film it's really powerful i'm so stoked
for you well the series finale of
supergirl is in a few weeks so did you
keep anything from the show and by that
i mean did you steal anything i did i
took a few things but no there for some
reason the props department i think
found like a tub of dinosaur figurines
somewhere and they would just put them
in random places of the catco office set
what i don't know
so i would see them and i had this weird
love of dinosaurs as a child we all love
dinosaurs as kids but my love of
dinosaurs i love them as adults in
movies that his daughter is in just
world yeah yeah yeah yeah
me too actually jurassic park was a huge
reason i loved them but i wanted to be a
panthers yes
but i wanted to be a paleontologist oh
you were in it yeah i was in it until my
parents took us to dinosaur ridge in
colorado which is a live dig and i saw
how
boring it was
paleontologists everywhere were like
whatever
like it's so interesting what is the
coolest thing
about being a part of this movie i think
the coolest thing about being part of
this movie in particular is that harley
quinn doesn't care about anything she's
just so crazy and it was so fun to be
with her and to just
mess around and be a kid on stage yes
that's so fun what's good when you
you'll learn that too just working on
different sets with different actors and
different people like especially if you
start out so nice with somebody that's
really cool and like lets you just be
you and isn't giving you know added
pressure those are the jobs you want um
so your character birds of prey is a
pickpocket so did you study hard for
that one
where is my wallet is what i'm saying
i would be careful with that
but um a magician from the magic castle
he came and taught me
how to pit pocket and how to work with a
little bit of magic and cards and i've
always wanted to go to the magic castle
i'm like what do they do there
i think it just seems like they
pickpocket that's what they want maybe i
don't want to go there i like my money
um so
so what is the key to stealing a wallet
just for asking for a friend well
well a magician never gives away their
secret oh i like you i like you
well we have a magician
so if you if both of you i always love
asking people this usually it's after
several drinks but don't drink um okay
so what superpower would you want if you
could pick any superpower
i think i'd want to be able to fly yes
because i
i mean
saving the world is great yeah but like
just to be able to like look at
everything and just like transportation
yeah so
i'll be there in a second yeah
yes well you've got a film with dwayne
johnson next right yes it's a superhero
movie it's called black adam
he plays black adam okay and um you know
i think he was one of the
only ones without the muscle suit
okay he didn't need he didn't need any
help
but uh but yeah it comes out next next
july that's exciting if you always want
to do a superhero thing i love superhero
stuff you know i mean
no i always wanted to play like the
hooker with a heart of gold who's like
you know it's like
you know i look at me when she said
no
i didn't mean like that i mean i'm a
hooker but no harder
yes you do you know just like you know
crying and laughing at the same time
whatever just yeah juxtaposition of
things that's only because that's how
comedians i want to play a serious role
people never want to see me seriously
right right right right yeah but i so it
was not something i ever
no that's true though that's true but
actually oh no because you know why why
i'm saying that i i actually find that
comedians are usually very intelligent
very witty and very deep so usually like
there's a lot of level and we have to
know every level because we perform for
different people like this audience i
would have to know how to perform for
each one of you so yeah exactly and and
i actually think that's why i said oh is
i was like actually i would love you in
a serious role because i think that
comedians do really well and i get why
you'd want to see if i hate acting but
if i was going to be an actor i would
want to be kathy bates in misery
that's a good one no one's seen it
coming
crazy just carry it around yeah yeah
yeah i'm gonna be crazy and just in a
freaking weird way yeah yeah i want to
play a serial killer or something yeah
yeah that sounds fun
yeah it was it fun though to play
superheroes it was so much fun to play
black canary i'm so in love with her i
mean she required that i do so many
things i'd never done before like
singing or you know i trained for over
five months to learn martial arts there
you lost me
yeah
i mean it was like i had to change my
diet and really put on a lot of muscle
and wow i lived in a constant state of
pain
no but you know i mean everything hurt
sitting down hurt walking hurt
or the bathroom hurt but that's awesome
though it's a female castle i love
that's what i love about the movie it's
this female caspeol just kicking but did
y'all get really close oh we had so much
fun it was pretty cool because we were
all in the thick of it and training and
hurting and just having fun and rosie
for some reason rosie perez the she was
kind of like the center of the fun you
know she would do things like she seems
like she would be oh she she knows how
to navigate yeah
we oftentimes ended up in her trailer
just taking shots
did the director know
that's amazing she told these things
after
she went to stutt training she would
bring this drink that she would make she
would just come with like a backpack and
out of the backpack would just be
sticking this bottle and like the top
you could see this top edge and it was a
drink that she would make a concoction i
think it's called like coquito coquito
yeah does anybody know it sounds like
that was yeah
[Laughter]
oh you have to have it if she comes to
my she better make me that drink it's
pretty i can't kick anyone's butt and i
don't want to work out for five months
but i want the drink
i want to earn it in some other way
so is it true i found this out that
margot robbie she she tattoos
people on set she tattoos the people she
works with did you let her tattoo your
body i planned it okay that that's a no
i have the intention i have an
appointment i think it's around thursday
no and there's a thing in fairness we
talked about this recently and she said
i have to come up with a tattoo that is
very simple and maybe we put it on a
place that is hidden just because she
messes it up that is not who i want
tattoo in my body
somebody that leads with just in case i
mess this up we should hide it it's like
i have like 15 tattoos so you can get
yeah they're hidden they're like a lot
of them are hidden okay they're very
addictive i don't have any tattoos well
you will once you start it's very
addictive but it's kind of cool to get a
tattoo from her maybe it's like your you
know initials of somebody or something
like i was thinking maybe my son or
something yeah that'd be cool yeah
you're always going to love him maybe
stick with that one
that's awesome it's like i was so sorry
for those people getting horses like on
them
well it's there forever
[Music]